let's see what should we talk about next
we've got a few more Clips here
okay so let's do this one over here
um
there was this guy that
put out this clip here Love Letters to
Jeffrey Dahmer
okay so this is a 13 minute or so I'm
kind of have to skip through it because
he does a lot of narration on it but I
want to show you the clips because it's
relevant to the type that title of this
of this particular video
share screen tab
okay
so this is a YouTube channel called
Bizarre Bazaar
and uh let's speed it up a little bit so
we can rip through it a little bit
faster
let's get started here
in this episode we're looking at the
other side of the coin so when I say
cereal killer you instantly think sexy
irresistible misunderstood witty I think
all right here I'm gonna skip up to some
of these letters so he's got the letters
here on the screen so these are love
letters sent to serial killer Jeffrey
Dahmer
okay this is the letter I'll be hiding
the identity of these women for obvious
reasons but these letters were all in
Jeffrey Dahmer's possession I'm going to
name this woman Sarah hi Jeff how are
you doing today by the way if you don't
know Jeffrey Dahmer was a homosexual
like he wasn't even attracted to women
I'm doing all right got sick of working
I've just got to find a better paint job
Jeff I want you to think about this I
walked into this bar around here and I
was too drunk to remember the name of it
well anyway I walked into this bar and
everyone started to laugh at me I said
after ordering a drink what's everybody
laughing at you were right by me you
said do you know what kind of bar this
is I said no you said it was a gay bar I
freaked out I didn't know what to think
or do at that moment so straight away in
this story she's using dammer as some
kind of emotional support you asked me
my name I told you Sarah you said your
grandmother it's just so weird like
she's like she's having a conversation
in a letter with a guy that has been
convicted for like murdering a bunch of
people he's not even straight the dude's
a homo like like he's a homosexual he's
not attracted to women right this is
just it just it just gets weirder the
more and more you kind of go through all
these letters name that I was pretty
drunk at the time it was late I told you
I wouldn't name my dog that he just
laughed the whole body first of all
that's not even funny down the might
laugh because he's nuts but I'm pretty
sure the rest of the bar wasn't hanging
off her every word it's just a weird
situation yeah she's just making up this
entire story let's find another one here
so there's another letter right about
here
I'm thinking out like you have this
connection from the get-go so I just
left I'm glad nothing bad happened I
know I'm not dreaming this up it really
happened to me the guy I was sitting by
said his name was Jeff do you remember
anything like that right so she's just
properly yeah she's Nutter that's for
sure
uh let's go to this part of this next
letter
a relationship on some make-believe
story I know I've seen you around here I
bet it was you well let me know okay
desperate my son thinks I'm obsessed
with writing you letters well my son
thinks I'm obsessed with writing like
could you imagine being This Woman's kid
knowing that your mom is setting letters
to a convicted serial killer that's not
even interested in women
I feel sorry for these kids man maybe I
have until I hear from you I'll keep
writing hopefully you'll answer me back
soon when I do visit you I will tell my
son as I said he's against me writing
you because you're a killer I've got no
idea how she knows what she's doing she
knows who she's talking to that's for
sure
there's another one up over here let's
grab this one
she's talking to Milwaukee's worst ever
criminal about how crimes are getting
bad in the area what well Jeff
tomorrow's another working day it's not
easy for me either I'm going through a
lot lately my two feels better today see
how relatable they both are be cool
though if you don't hear from me for a
while it just means I'm busy but we're
right again I check my mailbox well that
was so strong it feels like he's never
it's like she's got a relationship with
this dude
it's at this part bro it feels like he's
never applied once I wonder why there is
another letter for the same woman it's
even more cringe-worthy I'll just show
you some segments it's dated 5th 26 99
and it feels like this was sent after
the previous letter I hope you had a
chance to write me back that would be
nice hope things are good underlines
nice with an exclamation point write me
back that would be nice
for you I hope you like my letters have
you talked to a social worker yet about
sending me a visiting card I'll send it
right back to you so we can plan
something summer is here now do you ever
get to go outside do you have people now
that visit you on the weekends once I
get there how long can we visit together
I'm looking forward to this visit this
letter is mainly begging for attention
whilst being peppered with small talk as
soon as I get some film I'll have my son
take pictures of me for you oh my God
could you imagine being the kid that has
to take pictures of his mom so she can
send the pictures to Jeffrey Dahmer in
jail
maybe you'll write to me I hope so honey
I'm not ugly if that's what you think
Jeff I lost track of how many letters I
wrote to you already I really hope
you're getting them it just gets weirder
so clearly he's not even writing her
back either so her son is going to have
to take photos of her so she can send
them to gay serial killer Jeffrey Dahmer
in the hopes that he fancies at what
planet is she on
I'm really
I like this guy hoping I can see you
soon Jeff I really like you like I said
just want us to be better friends please
Jeff answer me back as soon as you can
it doesn't take much time to write me
back I find time to write you right we
have to move on from Sarah yeah dude's
in jail like he doesn't have time enough
look at all these letters man they just
go on and on and on I mean I don't know
do you guys want to keep going through
examples but these are yeah like you
know moth said it in the comment they're
basically women Sims right
um so there's a clip here that I got
it's a seven minuteer uh we'll play it a
little bit faster to tear through it of
course uh but this is a little bit of a
summarization uh from Huffington Post
with this uh I guess a reporter that has
visited the author of a book who's kind
of studied the phenomenon of women being
uh you know in love or writing Love
Letters to serial killers uh so let's
quickly look at this and then we'll uh
switch over and start taking some
call-ins from you guys here
um
why are women so fascinated by murderers
not dudes why are women
right it's a phenomenon that just exists
playback speed 1.5 let's do this sounds
like murders and stuff that's a top okay
oh we got the spinning wheel of death
here let me see if I can
fix that let's change the quality maybe
it's a quality issue people Network for
women ages 24 to 54 and I don't know why
women in particular luxury crime I can
justify my need to gulp at murder pretty
much but I've been reading about this
phenomenon where women aren't just
obsessed with the crime they're obsessed
with the Killer
foreign
yard doesn't seem to like me playing
this one for some reason let me just
make one more adjustment and if that
doesn't work
we'll just switch let's try this again
on where women aren't just obsessed with
the crime they're obsessed with the
killer take Chris Watts for instance he
killed his wife he killed his children
and he has all of these admirers these
women who are writing Love Letters to
him talking about how amazing this is
the same guy that I showed you the clip
on earlier with that um news reporter
he's so attractive are these women crazy
I I decided that I had to find out why
was this happening
so I wrote a letter to Chris Watts I
looked up his address his prisoner
number and it wasn't a love letter or
anything but I still wrote a letter
this whole area has got zero killer
vibes
currently driving to Upstate New York to
meet Sheila Eisenberg Sheila Eisenberg
he's the author of women who love men
who kill She interviewed a bunch of
these women and it's probably the best
study there exists today
all right so let's skip up ahead to
where she gets to the house
having me here my pleasure I loved your
crime but a lot of women liked your
crime uh what's wrong with me I don't
think there's anything wrong with you it
was just your interest yeah the question
is are more women than men interested in
True Crime then the next question is why
why would women be more susceptible to
this than men one possibility is I
really want to be tough I really want to
be violent myself but Society won't let
me I don't we're talking in
possibilities here but let's hear what
she has to say anyway yeah live
vicariously through
when I wrote this book I started
thinking about all the other stories I
knew of women who were involved with men
behind bars for murder
Wendy's girlfriend to Mary Wedding Bells
to sound for Ted and Carol Ted Bundy
asked Carol Boone to be his bride okay
and I thought like why Okay so
I'm assuming this is Ted Bundy in this
in this admirer of his uh that got
married to him in court is that what
happened
I started finding women yeah and then
interviewing them what were some of the
personality traits that you noticed most
of them had jobs they were married they
had children one woman had a PhD and was
a college professor this makes me even
more fearful that like this could happen
to me intelligence Personality yeah
doesn't really enter into it this isn't
that psychology what was it in their
past every woman had been abused in her
past bye again okay well there's
something
in her study anyway she says every woman
that she talked to had been abused in
her past
well
that to me would be red flag number 21
if I had to rewrite that list in my book
you don't want to deal with women that
have an infatuation with men that abuse
them
that's a red flag for sure man getting
involved with the prisoner or the lifer
they were in the dominant position
well there's a spinning wheel of death
again
this isn't an internet problem by the
way on my own some people come and go
why don't you just have a faster package
dude I've got the fastest package this
is a problem with stream yard
collaborating with that stream with this
stream so we'll see if it fixes itself
sometimes it's agreeable sometimes it's
disagreeable
they would make the prison visits they
would accept to collect phone calls all
right let's reduce this a little bit
more here
go to 360p this was also a way of
regaining control yes some sense
so I'm writing an Uber I'm going to
explore why women more than men are so
obsessed with True Crime when you look
at women who write to serial killers I
feel like okay well where is the line
when does my obsession become creepy and
problematic these women are not crazy
when you fall in love with someone it's
because that person feels your
psychological needs so being in a
relationship with a convicted she said
earlier at the start that the Avatar of
her
typical respondent when she was
interviewing them was married
these are married women that are falling
in love with criminals that are
incarcerated just just let that sink in
all right
the murderer is like being a star in a
romance novel all the time that makes it
sound really good well don't you get to
be my age you don't want that okay it
would be exhausting okay that's fair but
you know women who are writing to Chris
Watts right why are they attractive any
notorious killer had so many new stories
written about them you can't turn on the
television without a documentary or even
a feature film being made about one of
these people no and I'll probably watch
it if I'm honest and any woman who can
write to one of those people and get a
response and form a relationship she too
will be notorious Chris Watts or Scott
Peterson remember him he's similarly
notorious any of those people will
answer so she's saying essentially it's
about
attention and validation as well I mean
we already know that that's
you know that's a currency for women
it's important thanks for you 15 minutes
I think that's attractive to I think
everyone one of the basic human needs is
to be known we live in a celebrity
culture and it started with reality TV
the worship of celebrities and the
celebrity culture that began like 20 30
years ago has just morphed into this
crazy feast
why more women than men are obsessed
with crime True Crime and outlaws has to
do with the way culture still views
women we still don't have a woman
President we still don't oh here we go
here we go I knew this was going to come
the whole victim mindset we still don't
have a women President we still here we
go listen to this now I have more than
50 representing top ranks of
Corporations think how much Flack women
get from so
the reason why women have an infatuation
with serial killers and murderers is
because we haven't had a female
president or we haven't had 50
representation in the corporate world
like come on lady
being outspoken yeah that's very true
you're a [ __ ] if you're a tough man
it's like you're yeah you're taking
leadership
America is a country founded on you know
the wild west the cowboy tall lean mean
with two six shooters on his hip this
isn't a phenomenon unique to America
either I mean like I know that some
people live in a bubble in their head
but this is something that happens
throughout the Western World right
um women in the UK are infatuated with
serial killers and murders in fact some
of the letters that they were talking
about in one of these articles that were
going to Nicholas Cruz he was he was
talking to a woman in England about
having kids with her and he was talking
about naming his sons after Firearms
Remington kalishnikov it's hilarious
right
settling the frontier that's true that's
our history and then moving forward into
anyway that's Spinning Wheel of death
you know what we're going to pull this
out because
she's she started to lose some
credibility when she started whinging
and whining with the victim mindset
stuff we don't have a female president
that's why all these women are
infatuated with serial killers okay well
sure
um then I came across this over here
which is apparently Tumblr is popular
with the ladies
and if you type into Google search
Tumblr women that love serial killers
there's all kinds of these threads
um inside the Tumblr Community where
women worship Killers inside Tumblr
serial killer fandom problems uh serial
killers the Keller Technologies that's
another Tumblr threat I don't use Tumblr
So F yeah serial killers on Tumblr
[ __ ]
the secret obsessions of True Crime
Tumblr bloggers
serial killers on Tumblr yeah so like
you get the idea like this is a
phenomenon that's unique and
it seems like there's a bunch of
theories on it
but
I mean if you distill down the [ __ ]
and take away the blah blah blah the
reason why this happens because we
haven't had a female president it seems
like women are attracted to strong
powerful men that are able to do things
uh bad things in fact
um and it makes sense you know for
thousands of years for hundreds of
thousands of years human beings were
nomadic hunter-gatherers and women would
want to be with competent men that were
able to
you know defeat
killer animals the saber-toothed tigers
and warring tribes and if they came back
with blood on their hands I would
imagine and and food or uh you know like
as a uh as a winner you know like women
don't care about your struggles they
hang out at the Finish Line the pick you
know they pick the winners I've been
said or quoted many times and often
misquoted you know as it goes uh but
they're basically with the guy that was
competent enough to do those bad things
right so that's where my theory lies
with it um it seems like there's a few
other obsessions but it's a clear
Obsession anyway I haven't seen this
Jeffrey Dahmer thing on Netflix I try to
avoid watching long series like junk
junk [ __ ] like that because it's like
who cares
um but there you go hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
our lineup is broken down by category
that it performs best in estrogen
metabolism fat burning your foundational
Essentials for health immune Health
performance and testosterone support if
you check out with coupon code Alpha 10
you'll get 10 off on your first order
there's also the option to use the
Subscribe and save model or regular
shipments will be sent over to you on a
regular basis and that gives you a
little bit of a discount and your
supplement facts are always broken down
over here thanks for watching I hope you
guys have an awesome day and again check
out that link it's pinned in the top
comment below in this video peace out